[Music]
there was a uh
a missouri woman hmm is it missouri
misery what kind of tragedy you're gonna
tell us you're asking now at this age
missouri woman
is it property cheap property if looking
whoa man missouri
uh a missouri woman was awarded a 5.2
million dollar settlement against her
ex-boyfriend's car insurance company
geico
after she claimed that she got a
sexually transmitted disease from him
after they had sex in his 2014 hyundai
genesis and she won wow that's dope
the insurance companies paying for that
[ __ ] geico has to pay 5.2 million
dollars what's the reasoning behind that
i don't know
wow
that's insane america land of
opportunity and dreams things don't make
sense [ __ ] std is is it like something
terrible like chlamydia mono i have no
yeah
so imagine getting a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like roadhead and then you can sue the
insurance company that's sick so on
tuesday after five years of uncertainty
the missouri court of appeals affirmed
that geico general insurance company
must make the massive payout to the
jackson county woman in this
unprecedented case a three-judge panel
found that the judgment entered against
the insurance giant through earlier
arbitration proceedings was valid court
papers obtained by the daily mail
revealed that the woman notified geico
in february 2021 stating that she and
the insured had been in a romantic
relationship since 2017. the woman told
the insurance company her intention to
seek monetary damages alleging she
contracted hpv
the human papillomavirus papilloma virus
from an insured member hpv in his
automobile do you believe all women
court documents reveal that in the suit
i slipped for a second that was a really
good plug for that one
yeah you did it's like your car court
documents reveal that in the suit the
woman alleged that her ex-boyfriend had
been told that he had throat cancer
tumor
and was diagnosed with hpv yet he
continued to have unprotected sex with
her knowing the risks
i still don't know how this has to do
with it sounds like that catherine zeta
jones thing where she uh who's her
husband you mean the entrapment
[Laughter]
real yeah i heard that's a pretty common
thing like you get throw cancer from oh
because because of the net like hpv
i don't know i don't know exactly the
size
should i stop eating [ __ ]
well she in this one she's claiming that
she got the sc because he ate her out or
in the course and he has a throat cancer
right so he gave it to her so he was
being generous but he was a little too
generous and gave her more well
technically so so it says in may 2021
the arbitrator found that the man and
woman had sex inside his vehicle that
directly caused or directly contributed
to cause the hpv infection why and the
ex-boyfriend was found liable for not
disclosing his infection status and the
woman was awarded the 5.2 million damage
done in the car to be paid by geico
because the car is supposed to be
protection yeah
of the insurance he's the insured it's
like him via his car gone into an
accident with her and she got an std
from the accident
be like that i guess dude geico might
kill this guy you can
do they should kill this guy legit this
is the first probably case they're so
[ __ ] they're just like [ __ ] you're
like dude everyone has hpv everyone has
cars we're [ __ ] this is this is what
the attorney said yeah uh this is what
these trainings why did you tell her if
quote unquote if you think about it as
an injury sustained while in that
person's vehicle then it totally falls
within what an insurance company would
be required to pay it's an injury
sustained in his vehicle what a [ __ ]
discovery did he have did he have full
coverage general coverage
genital coverage
just a bunch of guilty [ __ ] ass
catholics and they're like
whoa they're [ __ ] in vehicles that's
weird and weird
huh i don't know or they're all like
wait if we all deliberate guilty we
could cash in on this afterwards
yup everybody's gotten hpv from a car
sex encounter right does everyone have
geico
one lady's like i'm switching i haven't
had sex but i'd love to rub my [ __ ] in
my car
i actually think i have geico holy [ __ ]
i can't i can't believe that's a what a
cool ass thing to find out america
everything happens one time everything
can happen and then after that the
contract gets changed yeah
the contract says like uh amendment
x-iii no sexual favors will not be
considered an insurance claim i feel
like you're born with it right sometimes
maybe it's maybelline
i don't know um but i heard that it's so
common like it's like one out of yeah or
some [ __ ] because it doesn't always
cause like uh problems yeah sometimes
it's just in you yeah so sometimes it
has to do with like a type of cancer
that can develop but otherwise yeah it
causes ovarian cancer in some way yeah i
think hpv it doesn't really show
symptoms in men but it does in women
i think that's where men pass it but
it's the most common one that every
people care yeah i willed with it yeah
human papalopia virus everyone deserves
5.2 million dollars in i'm telling you
95 papilloma
there's a long way
human your body's 60 water other parts
papilloma
human papillomavirus more quotes from
the attorney usually injuries to
passengers are the result of a collision
or slamming the door on one's fingers
that sort of thing but while a lawsuit
over contracting an std from the insured
driver may be the first of its kind this
award shows that it's not a stretch for
someone to file against an insurance
company for any actions occurring in a
motor vehicle just has got to get some
of those injury lawyers like saliva
they're so hard just be like dude can
you imagine because there must be other
things now besides you know just like
sex injuries let's let's think of some
right now sex injuries
emotional trauma oh yeah before getting
broken up
[ __ ] in the car
when we're looking at that one [ __ ]
retreat uh receipt where it's like a a
server adds a [ __ ] fee for emotional
like uh damage or something expenditure
or whatever the [ __ ] you exhausted
because you cried at a [ __ ] thing
it's like oh you made me like work
harder than normal so you should be to
charge the service fee or like the other
guy that we did article on where it's
like he couldn't blame or somebody got
killed in the car maintenance area or
something like that so they were suing
the car
dude like hey my wife
you know she was doing her makeup at
night while i was [ __ ] driving and
like that little light came on and i
[ __ ] freaked out whole car turned
over there's all kinds of arguments you
can make what if you're just riding the
car with someone and they said something
racist to you and then you're like oh
i'm going to shoot geico for that i'm
sure that's racist that's great yeah
that's echo ensures racists
emotional damage yeah
you're doing a drug deal
you you you and then you got shot in the
car because of the drug deal that you
did the deal went down
you gotta go
what about all like the domestic
violence cases that happens in cars like
can rihanna just sue chris brown for
like beating his her beating her ass in
the car specifically
that's true limitations probably ran up
on that specific case but you could
probably but can she see home depot for
providing the stairs that he threw her
down
they were they fought at home depot no
they fought
home people don't even have a second
story
in every aisle they got that little
[ __ ] orange stair fee you walk to
that story
let me show you something at the top and
then shove there [ __ ] dude
they had a fist fight at home depot he
was trying to get a new hammer that's it
did he push her downstairs he shoved her
right down the stairs yeah still still
stairs
and it's [ __ ] up he shoved it down
three flights so he kept on having to
roll and it was three flights of spiral
stairs dude
he kept having to go down to the spiral
standing and he kept on like yeah like
she like hit the wall because one of
those like yeah you know how it is moved
her over i rushed things let's be honest
he has made some sick music since i know
really good boss sample the sounds from
the stairs too
yeah i think so uh uh she's not you
shouldn't you
that's very innovative that's very kanye
wait did it he just get
in trouble for beating up another girl
no way okay wait that was in the past
joe no way i don't breathe like a couple
months ago yes but like it doesn't
matter because when you make sick music
you could beat up anything you're fine
in hip-hop
because he was just making those beats
if you don't beat up women you're not
hip-hop that's what it is right
oh [ __ ] it's not
r b unless you beat women i feel like
there are no that's peeing on on people
that's different
hip-hop by the way
those women knew and they could have
worn raincoats but they didn't
she could have brought her umbrella
everyone knew
everyone i saw the videos when i was in
high school you did isn't that
illegal because well i was illegal
okay that's that's a good point and
that's what i'm saying
and
everyone knew about chris brown so if
chris brown's current most girlfriend
isn't waking up putting on [ __ ]
football pads that's on her
i will say though chris brown
pre-beating his music was fired
absolutely fire it's fire yeah i don't
know if the beating had like actual
correlation to my emotional status on
his music but man his beats were [ __ ]
sick do you think you could respect the
artist not his like beating beats but
like his like uh songbeats or his
heartbeats
[Music]
hmm
[Music]